does light year fly to infinity and
beyond or is this pixar movie simply
falling with style you're mocking me
aren't you oh no no no no no no it's
been three years since toy story 4 wowed
audiences with another adventure from
sheriff woody and buzz lightyear but
pixar's latest offerings widens the toy
story franchise in a surprising new way
lightyear looks at the story behind the
toy with marvel alumnus chris evans
voicing the iconic astronaut who gets
stranded in the future after his test
flight goes wrong obviously this is the
character that the toy in the movies is
based on you actually think you're the
buzz lightyear lightyear director angus
mclean told io9 that the movie is a huge
hit in the toy story universe saying
i've always wondered what movie was buzz
from why couldn't we just make that
movie so that's what we did
lightyear is the movie that andy saw
that changed his life andy's star wars a
sci-fi epic designed to inspire a new
generation it's a fascinating way of
expanding the toy story world without
churning out another sequel based on the
iconic toys lightyear also introduces
the in-universe version of emperor zerg
buzz's robotic arch enemy who has
devious plans for the rest of the
universe thankfully the hero of star
command has a ragtag team of unlikely
sidekicks on his side to help him stop
zerg and get back to his own time taika
ytt voices mo morrison alongside dale
soules as darby steele two survivors in
the future while kiki palmer voices izzy
hawthorne the granddaughter of buzz's
best friend alicia hawthorne but did
light years soar with critics or did it
fail to launch while most reviewers on
rotten tomatoes think pixar has another
hit on its hands the first light year
reviews have arrived online ahead of the
film's release on june 17th and it looks
like fans are in for a fun ride across
the universe the movie currently has an
82 critic rating on rotten tomatoes
which is a positive sign that the
spin-off has been worth the wait linda
merrick of the jewish chronicle gave the
film a glowing review writing with some
clever nods to some classic space sagas
from alien to interstellar mclain and
co-writer jason headley have delivered a
love letter to the genre all the while
bringing that unmistakable fuzzy feeling
we've come to expect from pixar's ever
expanding stable
obviously some audiences will be
wondering whether lightyear will tie
into the toy story movies in smaller
ways but mashable's kristy putchko says
the real focus here is its own story
this spin-off pays tribute to the buzz
that's come before with callbacks to his
lines look gadgets attitude and more and
even though it walks in the shadow of
the giant that is toy story light year
manages to set its own course for fresh
adventure developing an origin story
within a franchise like toy story is a
difficult task but it seems that
director angus mclean has found the
perfect balance the film has made
headlines for being banned in several
countries due to a same-sex kiss but
ign's emilia ember wing thinks the film
handles it well saying
light year features striking visuals
strong performances and a love out loud
lesbian relationship that we're thrilled
to see on screen all of those things
deserved a stronger story though however
not everyone was won over by buzz's
adventures that was utterly terrifying
and i regret having joined you although
many reviews embraced lightyear for its
fun trip across the cosmos other critics
blasted the spin-off for feeling like an
easy cash grab keith watson tore into
the animated movie for slant saying
the film is a slick soulless spectacle
whose jokey banter and space opera
action drowns out the story's emotional
beats this review and others argue that
the film might try too hard to be like
other iconic sci-fi movies rather than a
classic in its own right alongside so
many other well-known pixar movies the
telegraph's robbie collin was also
unimpressed with the spin-off noting the
problem with pixar's latest feature
isn't just that it's the animation
house's dullest dreariest most
spiritually empty to date it's that it
fails even on its own painstakingly
contrived open goal terms
ouch it seems the real problem is that
pixar has already set the bar too high
for what animated movies can do making
light year feel like a middling effort
in comparison finally bbc's nicholas
barber thinks it's missing the childlike
sense of fun and wonder saying whatever
escapades young andy imagined in 1995
when he was playing with his space
ranger toy they were bound to be more
fun than this one
to infinity
are you trying to get me to pull your
finger don't fall for it light year
arrives in theaters on friday june 17th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]